Speaker 1: Hey, this is really, really funny.
Karl Rove wrote an op ed in the Washington in
The Wall Street Journal called Where Do Trump's
Donations Go? And it's a very good question. Karl
Rove points out he can't spend his tax millions on
2024 because he's not running. He's not using yet.
He's not using the money really to
support midterm candidates based on the
spending disclosures that we've seen. And I
will add to that that yesterday we found out
that the Republican National Committee is paying
Donald Trump's legal bills. So what the hell is
Trump spending the money on? And Karl Rove,
who is an anti-Trump Republican strategist,
says What will Donald Trump do with his campaign
cash? Trump controls for PAC Save America. Make
America Great Again. Again. Trump Make America
great again and Make America great again. Action.
The PAC's cash on hand as of June 30th came to
103 million, 10 million, 7.3 million and 700 K.
That puts $121 million at Trump's disposal. Small
donors were pummeled with requests for Trump's
causes. In a 24 hour stretch this week, writes
Karl Rove I received 25 fundraising pleas from
the Trump world beseeching me to help America four
from the Democrats Save America for the Democrats.
In exchange for donations, I was offered
a trump card, a blue one, then a gold one,
then a T-shirt, then wine glasses, then my name on
the donor wall and all of these different things.
And money is flowing in to Trump's various
PACs. But what is he going to do with the money?
Karl Rove, right. One option is convert the money
to a presidential campaign. According to federal
election lawyers. That's one possibility. What can
Trump use the cash for now? Well, he can support
other candidates, but he's not really doing that.
He could do independent expenditures on behalf of
candidates buying ads and this sort of thing for
other candidates. But Trump hasn't done much of
that either. What exactly is going to happen with
this money? And Karl Rove writes, If Trump doesn't
start deploying these funds to help the candidates
he's backing, donors might not keep giving. Now,
there I disagree with Karl Rove. There is a
cult of personality around Donald Trump where
he could even admit I'm using the money to hire my
family and refurbish my private jet and whatever.
And the vast majority of his followers would
say, all right, I mean, it sounds like he needs
the private jet and his family are some of the
smartest people. So it makes sense to give them
the cult actually wouldn't really care. But it
is an extraordinarily consistent question that
we have, because in the immediate aftermath of the
2020 election, remember when Trump lost but said,
we're going to raise money and we're going to
audit this and we're going to recount that,
and we're going to do all these different things.
And they didn't do it in the fine print. It
said up to 50% or in some cases more of your
donation can be used to pay off campaign debt.
And so it's almost certainly some kind of
grift. We just don't know what it is yet. Now,
there's another kind of just bigger picture thing.
Is Trump going to try to use the money to support
other candidates, but not just out of the goodness
of his heart. Conditionally in exchange for favors
support in 24, whatever. That's the other idea,
which is Trump will ultimately relent. And as we
get closer to the November midterms now, we're
only just a, you know, a little bit over three
months away, Trump will start to deploy the
money for the people that he's supporting,
but in exchange for vows of loyalty going into
2024. Let me know your thoughts. What do you
think Trump's raising the money for? What do
you think he's going to use the money for? But
a great question from Karl Rove. Where are the
donations actually going? Make sure that you are
following me on Twitter at David Pakman. Let
me know where do you think the donations are
going and of course make sure to sign up at join
Packman dot com. The program is viewer supported
and I would love to have your support. We're going
to take a quick break. It is a packed Friday show
chock full of content as the kids these days say.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer and listener
supported program, which you can support directly
telling you it's. We pay 2% to swipe credit and
debit cards and otherwise everything else comes
to us. At join Packman dot com sign up. Get a
membership. It's a fantastic thing. And if you
want a membership you can use the discount code
Obama bomb. Now you'll save some. It's got to be
about 60%. I mean, it's a criminal discount code